[Música]
Rusia suspendió su participación en el
acuerdo de Estambul que permitía la
exportación de granos desde los puertos
ucranianos del mar Negro una decisión
que según los medios estatales rusos
responde a los supuestos ataques
ucranianos contra buques en el puerto de
sebastopol Ucrania denuncia un pretexto
para bloquear el corredor
los dos aspirantes a la presidencia de
Brasil cruzaron Reproches ayer en un
último debate de Cara a la segunda
vuelta de mañana el izquierdista Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva y el actual
mandatario ultraconservador Yahir
bolsonaro se acusaron mutuamente de
mentir la economía la pandemia y el
aborto fueron temas centrales
la guardia Revolucionaria de Irán
advirtió a los manifestantes no salir a
las calles asegurando que hoy es el
último día de disturbios una amenaza
tras la intensificación de las protestas
desde que el miércoles se cumplieran 40
días de la muerte de bajo custodia de la
policía de la moral Tenemos reporte
desde Terán
Buenos días Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición con información
relacionada con la guerra en Ucrania
porque Rusia anunció que se retira del
acuerdo de Estambul alcanzado en junio
que permitía la exportación de granos
ucranianos por el mar Negro
Moscú declaró que notificará
oficialmente su retirada al secretario
general de Naciones Unidas que junto con
Turquía me dio en el acuerdo con kiev un
acuerdo que hasta la fecha ha permitido
la exportación de 9 millones de
toneladas de grano a regiones de todo el
mundo afectadas por la falta de
alimentos por lo que tanto Ucrania como
Naciones Unidas urgen a Rusia que
mantenga el pacto la decisión comunicada
por el Ministerio de defensa ruso se da
en respuesta a los presuntos ataques
ucranianos en la Bahía de sebastopol en
la Península de crimea
Moscú considera su territorio además el
kremlin acusa al Reino Unido de
participar en la planificación tanto de
estos ataques como de los del Norte
Stream señalamientos que Londres rechaza
y la escalada de la ofensiva rusa se
hace centrado en gran parte en atacar
infraestructura estratégica como el
sistema energético de Ucrania el viernes
las autoridades de kiev anunciaron que
en las grandes ciudades los apagones
empeoran el alcalde de la capital
advirtió que la red eléctrica de la
ciudad funciona en modo de emergencia
con niveles de energía reducidos hasta
en un 50%, Respecto a los niveles
previos a la invasión
en este restaurante de kiev los
comensales se han acostumbrado a comer a
la luz de las velas se han introducido
cortes de energía programados en la
capital de Ucrania ya que Rusia ha
apuntado repetidamente a la red
eléctrica de la nación
creo que la energía se va a cuatro veces
por semana
y cada vez dura cuatro horas
los recientes ataques con drones han
destruido el 30% de las centrales
eléctricas de Ucrania en una semana
mientras las autoridades instan a sus
ciudadanos a reducir drásticamente el
consumo
a partir de este momento muchas ciudades
y regiones de nuestro país utilizan
horarios de bloqueo de estabilización
casi 4 millones de ucranianos se
enfrentan actualmente a estas
restricciones la mayoría de las ciudades
importantes se han visto obligadas a
implementar medidas de ahorro de
Electricidad sin precedentes que se
reparten con el uso de los trenes para
quitar presión a la red es harkif las
calles se sumergen en la oscuridad todos
los días con canales de tiempo frente a
las pocas opciones los residentes
recurren a bancos de energía para
mantenerse conectados pero no es
suficiente después de que se corta la
electricidad aproximadamente una hora u
hora y media más tarde toda la red
telefónica está cortada y en
consecuencia tampoco tenemos internet en
nuestros teléfonos los proveedores
privados de electricidad en el bif y
chernify han reducido horarios para
limitar el consumo de Electricidad de
las Industrias pero mientras tanto las
alertas de bombas suenan casi todo el
tiempo además de la gran escasez de
personal que a menudo no permite la
reparaciones de las centrales eléctricas
el equipo dañado es único es difícil de
encontrar repuestos y la producción de
nuevos toma mucho tiempo
con el invierno acercándose rápidamente
se está acabando el tiempo para
asegurarse de que las luces permanezcan
encendidas en Ucrania
cambiamos de información vamos con
noticias de nuestra región porque en
Brasil la mayoría de los selectores ya
tienen claro su voto el debate de este
viernes que estuvo lleno de ataques
basados en las creencias y en el
historial de los candidatos Lula Y
bolsonaro al parecer no causó mayores
cambios en la intención de Voto nuestros
enviados especiales a Sao Paulo Ángela
Gómez Lionel y Natalia plazas
consultaron a varios ciudadanos sobre
sus impresiones a un día del balotaje
veamos
el debate de este viernes entre Lula da
Silva y Jair bolsonaro en Río de Janeiro
fue la última oportunidad de los
candidatos para traer electores cuando
falta apenas un día para que sean las
elecciones que podrían ser además las
más apretadas y las más tensas en la
historia del país en ese contexto
preguntamos a los ciudadanos Cuál es su
opinión sobre ese encuentro tan
emocional y con tantas respuestas
fuertes por parte y parte yo batch
no me gustó el debate realmente no me
gustó me pareció que fue muy agresivo
entre los candidatos
me pareció medio deprimente medio
deplorable porque era uno atacando al
otro no tuvo contenido no tuvo
propuestas
un mejor desempeño de lo que se esperaba
en primera vuelta lo que los medios
locales reportan es que no ha habido
grandes modificaciones en su campaña que
le permitan hacer una mayor captación de
votantes Sin embargo aquí nada está
escrito lo que hicimos fue preguntarles
a los ciudadanos de a pie y el debate de
noche generó algún cambio en su voto
democracia y voto es por Lula por la
democracia y es porque evolucionaron
cada vez más se fundamenta en mentiras
en la planificación que él dio a Brasil
y también a otros países hay medidas que
deben ser tomadas y que él deja en
debate entonces Mi voto es por nula
Bogotá
no cambió voy a votar por bolsonaro y
mis convicciones siguen siendo las
mismas porque yo me alineo más con las
pautas que él propone sobre el otro
candidato
A poco más de 24 horas de que Brasil
pueda proclamar es un nuevo ya fueron
movilizados todos los materiales
electorales todo está listo para que
mañana los votantes salgan masivamente a
emitir su voto por su candidato y el día
de hoy en Sao Paulo Pues será el cierre
de campaña de Lula da Silva por la
avenida paulista mientras que bolsonaro
hará su Cierre en Minas gerais
vamos ahora a Estados Unidos porque la
policía de San Francisco determinó que
el ataque al esposo de la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes del país
Nancy pelosi fue intencional el ataque
tuvo lugar ayer recordemos viernes por
la mañana cuando un hombre entró en la
residencia de Paul pelosi de 82 años
buscando a su mujer a Nancy pelosi la
persona con el tercer cargo político más
importante de Estados Unidos El asalto
Aviva los temores de violencia política
a diez días de las elecciones
legislativas de medio término Rafael
Pérez nos cuenta más
un ataque intencional así calificó la
policía de San Francisco la agresión
sufrida por el esposo de la presidenta
de la cámara de representantes de
Estados Unidos Nancy pelosi
basados en nuestra investigación en este
momento sabemos que esto no fue un acto
al azar fue intencional y está mal
de 82 años Fue embestido a martillazos
en su casa por un intruso las heridas de
la víctima fueron significativas pero sí
fue llevado un hospital local donde fue
intervenido por una fractura de cráneo
además de presentar lesiones en el brazo
derecho la plana mayor demócrata no
tardó en reaccionar
ya es suficiente ya es suficiente toda
persona de buena conciencia debió
ponerse claramente y sin ambigüedades a
la violencia en nuestra política
independientemente de cuáles sean sus
políticas
el presidente reiteró que la frase del
atacante que Preguntaba dónde está Nancy
también se escuchó en los pasillos del
Capitolio durante la toma del 6 de enero
de 2021 la vicepresidenta Harris
calificó el suceso como un hecho por
debajo de la dignidad y la inteligencia
de los Estados Unidos
Esto fue un acto de extrema violencia y
creo que
estamos nuestro país donde hay un
discurso muy alimentado por el odio y la
división
[Música]
el estado actual de polpelos y es
prometedor los médicos afirmaron que el
tratamiento a sus heridas fue exitoso y
esperan una recuperación completa El
asalto se dio en un contexto electoral
avivando así los temores de violencia
política Estados Unidos se encuentra a
días de las elecciones de medio término
que decidirá Cuál de los dos grandes
partidos se hace con el control del
congreso
en Irán las autoridades acusan a las
periodistas que revelaron la muerte de
maxam Mini bajo custodia de la policía
de la moral y cubrieron su funeral de
estar entrenadas por la Cia se trata de
nilufar hamedi y el aje Mohamed dos
profesionales muy reconocidas en el país
que están encarceladas sin juicio y sin
que se sepa exactamente Qué cargos pesan
en su contra se trata de una nueva
acusación de injerencia extranjera por
parte de Teherán el mismo día que el
comandante de la guardia Revolucionaria
joseín salami amenazó a los
manifestantes diciendo que hoy sería el
último día de protestas nuestra
corresponsal entera en Catalina Gómez
Ángel nos amplía
Esta no es la primera Obviamente el
general es la máxima figura los guardias
revolucionarios pero no es la primera
vez que desde esta institución y de
otras instituciones de la república
islámica se da por sentado que las
protestas no van a seguir existiendo en
el mismo momento que él daba esas
declaraciones en la ciudad de chiradas
en el sur occidente del país en ese
funeral en el cual se conmemoraba y se
recordaba a esas 15 personas fallecidas
en el atentado proclamado por Isis el
pasado miércoles a esta misma hora se
llevaban a cabo protestas no solamente
en varias universidades de Teherán sino
en otras ciudades más pequeñas del país
y esto se daba por diferentes motivos
porque habían sido atacado los médicos
en algunas universidades porque los
estudiantes no creen la versión de la
República islámica de que el atentado en
chiras haya sido llevado por el estado
islámico discurso incluso acusan a las
mismas autoridades o también en algunos
funerales de personas que murieron
durante el fin de semana Así que hay que
esperar es muy probable que esto se
termine con esta proclamación de del
General salami pero habrá que verlo las
próximas días
vamos ahora a somalia donde dos
automóviles bomba explotaron en la
capital mogadillo en una zona cercana a
edificios gubernamentales a esta hora
las autoridades reportan al menos 9
muertos mientras ninguna organización ha
reivindicado el atentado sin embargo el
ataque se produjo en el momento en que
el gobierno estaba reunido para discutir
uno de sus principales objetivos
políticos la estrategia en la guerra
contra el grupo afiliado al qaeda al
shabat que controla parte del país y es
responsable de mortíferas masacres como
la ocurrida hace cinco años en 2017 en
la misma localización exactamente cuando
el grupo armado hizo estallar un camión
bomba y mato a 500 personas
Muchísimas gracias por su atención sigan
con nosotros en francés 34 y Fran 34.com
[Música]